so with that being said about the
technological component watching cable
news shift right now there's also an
issue that a lot of people are getting
their news from this from them so shows
like this Shapiro bro and all of these
guys that's kind of worrying too at some
level right and I say that I'm talking
about guys that I love but like just
that you know the fact checking is
different here then say it would be on
cable news not that cable news is not a
great job no but you're right I mean
we're part you know we're we're always a
point on a continuum and we're in the
middle of a cycle where the media are
being reinvented completely and you're
right I mean the problem with individual
operators solo guys on YouTube is they
have so much less to lose than a
television network does that the
incentives to get the facts right to be
responsible of course much lower the
problem is you well know better than
anybody is that the the media have so
discredited themselves that it's like
it's so obviously propaganda yeah but
did you ever think it could be that bad
everywhere every day I look at a story
from CNN or political get BuzzFeed and
forget the really bad ones Vox and it's
like everything you guys are doing every
headline the way every Republican has a
picture that they look awful in the
picture Democrats look great and like
every little thing it's like they're
just smashing us with it they just
turned it up to 11 and I've well I mean
I grew up in a media family I mean my
dad was anchor here in LA of ABC and so
I have always lived in this world and I
always thought the media are liberal but
I was totally wrong about that they're
not ideologues actually they're party
people that's what I totally missed yeah
they're loyal to the party they feel
powerless except as part of a group that
is the main distinction between left and
right in this country and so whatever
the Democratic Party's imperatives are
they will act on them if the Democratic
Party invaded Canada tomorrow you would
see I'm serious they'd be like you know
these Canadians they live among us
they're you know what I mean they're a
fifth column like they would actually do
it doesn't matter what the part does
they will defend it
once you understand that then it all
makes sense they feel threatened that's
the truth and you and people like you
are the main threat to them it's not me
actually I'm on a competing medium but
in the same medium they are they know
that their power is ebbing and when you
feel like you're losing control that's
when you try to assert control that's
when the most ludicrous propaganda comes
when you feel like you know oh my gosh
they're not listening to me yeah but the
funny part is I oh and I tweet this all
the time it's like if these guys had
just been like pretty bad yeah I think
it would have been tolerable people
would have because they've been
happening for so long people kind of
wooded and have noticed that maybe they
could have got a little worse and we
would have been ok with it but it's like
they've just completely bottomed out and
well this is one of the the criticisms
of Trump that has a lot of truth in it
when people are like well he's a
destroyer he destroys everything he
touches you know probably an
overstatement but he does you know you
get close you sit and stare at Trump all
day and you're gonna burn out your
retinas okay and that's one of things I
try not to do I don't do a show about
Trump I didn't write a book about Trump
yeah I'm not against Trump I think Trump
is useful in a truth-teller in some ways
but but the people who obsess about
Trump are destroyed and that would
include his opponents maybe especially
his opponents so what would you do to
get some of those people back if they're
if they're out there now the ones that
really are overboard on Trump that I
haven't you know I've been able to reach
some some liberals some good lefties and
liberals so that okay we can put a hand
out for them but for the people that are
really feeling like they're buying all
the nonsense right is Hitler and all of
this really do you have any technique
that give us sure I mean I almost never
argue about Trump I really try not to I
mean the Platonic ideal for me of a show
is never mentioning Trump because I try
to take the long view I mean look other
shows had different roles you know
everybody sees like you know his or her
specific task but I feel like mine is to
try to take the long view not easy in
the middle of this news cycle of course
I get caught up all the time and that
you know the [ __ ] of the day but but
but I really try to think about like
well how would this look ten years from
now like Trump will be gone I'll be gone
we'll all be gone because we actually
die at the end it turns out so but I
want
the culturally 19 10 years but I didn't
say what kind of country do you want
that's the question do you want to live
in a place where the individual has the
right to dissent and I think most people
would say yes I do
yeah is that why the free speech stuff
has become so important to you well I
think you that it wasn't foundational I
mean that's just if they can tell you
what to say they can control what you
think and if they can control you think
you're not fully human and so you're
really you're not fighting for a
political party or an ideology or
fighting for your humanity I believe
that that's what I was taught as a child
by liberals yeah and they were right and
I bought it then by the way and so the
ACLU stood up for Clarence Brandenburg
who was not only a literally a Klansmen
from Ohio but a [ __ ] like a literally a
[ __ ]
he was the least appealing person ever
and they staked their entire credibility
on defending this guy why'd they do that
they did it of course to preserve the
absolute right of free speech for the
rest of us and they made the country
better when you abandon that yeah dude
it's over and now you see what comes out
of the ACLU and you're like you're not
you're not defending free speech you're
clearly a progressive group they're
opposing for tonight they issued a
statement saying you know some speeches
is too offensive really because you
defended the right of Nazis to march
through Skokie which everyone forgets
had the highest percentage of Holocaust
survivors of any town like outside
Israel yeah I mean it was the most
offensive thing you could do and they
defended it and they lost a lot of money
doing it like they lost a ton of
donations doing it but they defended the
principle and I noticed you've got an ad
in strawsons book yeah should we talk
right there here so there are people
like her or Dershowitz or these former
ACLU board members who are like totally
bewildered by this not because we care
about the ACLU as an institution who
cares it's some dumb nonprofit but
because the principles are literally
foundational yeah all right so let's
let's jump back for just a second here
so I want to talk about Fox generally
yeah so first off you guys are doing
something right and I don't mean just
you here clearly if you look at the
ratings I just looked at this thing and
it's like the last bottom 20 shows are
all CNN yeah the top ten are basically
all Fox maybe there's one MSNBC
in there beyond just you what do you
think that Fox is just doing right you
know being slightly different I mean I
you know I would argue that the thing I
mean I can only speak for my char I'm
only in charge of an hour of love 24 but
you know that it's actually worth
defending the principles as distinct
from the individuals or the political
figures and over time like you're not
embarrassed to do that it's worth doing
but I think as a business matter and
just sort of a matter of life if you're
the guy who's not entirely with the herd
and you know I can actually no I it's a
little bit different you know you go to
the 19 other stores and you can buy this
one product and I've got a different
product I mean I don't why is that bad
yeah so that just seems obvious thing is
how offensive that is yeah it's like fog
and I've worked I've worked at CNN I've
worked at MSNBC I worked at PBS I worked
at Esquire I mean I've worked at like a
million different liberal publications
and television channels and they're all
selling exactly the same product and
then there's Fox in the mainstream
landscape that's different just one
channel is different and the the feeling
overwhelming feeling is that should not
be allowed like I can't believe that
they're allowed to say what they're
saying we need to shut them down
well that's the irony it's like you guys
are the only ones that will put me on I
will gladly go on see you can't get on
those channels I've never been asked I
can't just show up there and bang on the
door but you guys call me and nobody
every time I've done your show it's live
I never know what you're gonna have
course and and same thing with some of
the other shows and it's like I will go
where I can talk to people exactly I
don't I don't want to be edited and
misrepresented which so I don't know
that I would trust a lot of these others
no okay so that's sort of what it's just
so uninteresting I mean if everybody's
saying repeating the exact same Pyatt
ease diversities or strength or children
or a future whatever the sort of
banality is that you think is profound
if everybody is saying the exact same
thing like that's just boring I like to
have I like to have people on who
surprised me like what you do you know
what I mean like that just because again
I'm more curious I mean I'm a human
being I want to think about things does
it ever drive you crazy to just be in
the in the constraints of what
television is you know like because
we've done segments where it's like you
know we've got
maybe six minutes and I feel like I just
started I mean you're like Ruben I'll
see you next time you know yeah I mean I
was a writer before I went into TV and
one of the reasons that I failed a
couple of times pretty spectacularly in
TV is because I didn't understand the
medium and I didn't respect it I was
like I'm a writer I'm a deep person Here
I am in the shallow medium and what I
didn't understand is that TV is it's
completely it's a completely different
thing yeah and it's got its own
requirements and its own rules and you
need to understand what it's capable of
it's capable of great things it's just
not capable of everything you know what
I mean it's not capable of explaining
concept complex concepts just that's not
what TV is about yeah I was four is it
odd to you that the interview the real
long-form this like just sit down with
another human being that you know CNN
booted Larry King which I think was the
beginning of the end for them so smart I
think that's I really believe it I mean
they saw I've never heard anybody else
say that but I argued that when I worked
there yeah so you so you were because
they were getting rid of me I think he
told me he was here a couple weeks ago
he said I thought it was the number one
rated show still on the network it was
number two at the time and they said no
no we're done 30 years adios right and
they also ended crossfire which had
become a kind of perversion of its
former self but I was in both versions
of it and at one point crossfire was
like a public service you know to sort
of equally manage did something shift
with crossfire because I do remember
watching you on cross well I mean it was
so it became partisan yeah which is
uninteresting yeah nobody wants to hear
what your team thinks we already know
what's interesting is when we throw up
an idea or policy and we deconstruct it
and we have two fairly evenly matched
people you know kind of competing for
you you know like so anyway became
something much more but the idea was
always a good idea and especially the
idea of Larry King I pitched that show
to many different channels black curtain
two people hour-long conversation and my
argument was this will rate people want
this there's none of it and everyone's
like yeah I don't think so we need
interstitials and graphics and it's like
they love interstitials it's
unbelievable and now of course with
YouTube it's like you look at the
numbers that you're getting and others
are getting with that exact format and
they're huge yeah it turns out yeah of
course there's a market for that why
would
there be how much of all of this
everything we're discussing here and and
so much what you're doing a show is just
that people are just tired of having
their intellect insulted totally
completely well look at television
versus movies if you had told me thirty
years ago that the most interesting you
know visual art being created would be
in television scripted television like
what no I don't think so
that's the province of [ __ ] right full
house but um but it turned out to be
true that for Bob Saget all right
actually no Bob Saget I like Bob Saget
but he's actually very smart yeah but
the point is that there is especially
when we're all narrowcasting when you
don't need to reach you know eighty
million people when you can reach three
million and that is a more than viable
commercial proposition you can aim at an
audience that wants that and there's a
substantial audience that does yeah okay
so Fox News we get it some things are
clearly going right and by ratings and
everything else is there anything that
Fox is doing that you think is wrong is
it too close to the President or
anything you know I mean I mean I'm
obviously I'm dodging the question even
if I had a real answer I would run from
that question because I work there but
if I'm being completely honest no I'm
not a huge I'm so caught up in our our
and I'm so it's such a hive in my show
and we have like you know I
intentionally hired really smart smarter
than I am people that I don't have a
sense sometimes of the larger
programming I would say as a general
matter I've always tried not to be
aligned with any politician because in
the end no matter how sympathetic I
might be to the message it's a
politician and I'm not if I want it to
be a policymaker I would be one there's
a pretty low bar for that it turns right
exactly so do you ever think about it
not for two seconds yeah I would never
want mean I live in that world so I know
what it is I don't want that I have a
journalist temperament I like to watch I
like the freedom to say what I really
think is true I don't want one thing I
will say about Fox which I'm grateful
for every single day and this is Rupert
they don't they do not control what you
say I've had this show for two years
almost exactly two years now a single
time as someone called it well no one
calls me at all but like no one calls it
as like I can't believe you said there's
nothing like that yeah if pure editorial
freedom so like why is that not a great
job yeah no I mean and I know it again I
just want to illustrate because people
don't understand that every time I have
gone on your show that we you know they
give me a some sense of what we're gonna
talk about yeah and that's it we go
alive its life and if you want to say
something insane like we can't stop you
yeah you know and and I would say the
other thing is the way TV works at least
at our network but I think this is true
when I worked at the others it was also
true the shows have enormous autonomy
they really do I mean there's not a
morning call where it's like here's our
line on this or that or the other it's
like I never talked to any I talked to
my executive producer Justin Wells for
my love and a lot of my other producers
all morning and she's in the car parked
outside I was just doing the show like
here's what I think we should do there's
I mean we can do whatever we want
yeah what's what's your day-to-day like
over there so I know what it's like to
do I do a couple shows a week and I'm
doing long-form and this way but we're
not doing a zillion segments and all and
all the interstitials and all that stuff
what's your sort of day-to-day Tucker
wakes up he's got a show that night
yeah I mean I try and I'm married I've
been married for 27 years I really like
my wife my kids are all gone so I really
try and stay home I mean the key in
daily TV is not to go insane that
actually is like the whole deal right
there if you can keep from becoming an
insecure sort of bag of neuroses do you
mean that just because of the media
criticism and just your constant
worrying about ratings it made the whole
thing with that but just the medium
itself leaves most anchors at some point
feeling totally exposed and alone it's
like I'm out here you know I've got a
staff of 80 people or whatever but in
the end I'm out here live it's just me
I'm taking all the crap and no one's
backing me up I mean every person in the
business feels that way at a certain
point and then you start to feel like
you know no one understands it you know
what I mean and you actually become so
self pitying and self-involved that no
matter how much they pay you you're
deeply unhappy and then you start acting
in erratic ways and like
look at TV and you know exactly who's
going through this right everybody
except me
because I keep my world so small you
know I married my high-school girlfriend
I live walking distance from my dad and
my brother and my college remainin best
friend and that's who I talk to every
day every day and I and the reason I do
that is because I love them but also
because I don't want to feel the way
that most people on TV do I want I want
to talk to people I love and trust and
and I want my security and happiness to
come from those relationships and not
from the affirmation I get on television
because you will become a crazy person
someone once said to me a head of a TV
network once said what do you think my
job is I said I don't know running a TV
network and he goes no it's keeping
millionaires from killing themselves my
job and yet how dark is that that's also
true it's like his job was to keep the
people from going totally bananas
because the medium itself drives you
crazy and you're doing this no booze no
cigarettes anymore no you got any vice
the booze is easy drinking coffee drink
pop oh you know I drink a lot Voltaire
levels of coffee yeah not a quite as
impressive effects but yeah and I quit
smoking four or five years ago and but
I'm you know I wouldn't call it a vice
but I'm not I'm enthusiastic user of
nicotine gum and lozenges because I
think they really have improved my life
like a lot I think I mean I don't want
to you know endorse yeah the product but
I sure what the downside is of using
nicotine there's a huge downside from
smoking of course the tar gives you
cancer and emphysema but I don't think
that we've shown that nicotine for
people who don't have blood pressure
problems and I don't hurts you and I
think there's a lot of evidence that
that's great yeah all right so I want to
spend the remaining time really focusing
on the book we sort of did yeah yeah I
think we did everything I believe we did
everything else but let's really focus
in on the book okay if if we're on the
brink of a revolution
what are your prescriptions to save us I
mean I think the first thing you need to
do is cool the temperature
little bit presidents not good at that I
mean that's not his by temperamentally
he's incapable of doing that I don't
think he sees it as an important thing
to do so is that do you think the
fundamental like sort of if we're
looking at this just that at a base
level that that that trumps temperament
and the way the media is with him is
that sort of the root of every ounce the
volatility is the problem I mean I think
that we needed to awaken the people in
charge not simply our political system
but also of our economy in our culture
from their stupor you know hey you're
not listening we're gonna like this
orange guy to wake you up I actually
think that was a useful thing a
necessary thing but repeated cycles of
political volatility like break your
country obviously there are million
examples of this that's obvious so you
need to calm people down in the main way
you calm people down is the way you calm
children down which is you explain to
them as simply and clearly as you can
why what's happening is happening while
you're making these decisions and you
give them some sense that they have some
control not total control but some
control over the decisions that you're
making you know you and franchise them
you bring them in and in a democracy you
need you need to make the system is
predicated on the idea so you need to
say to people look you know you want X Y
& Z you elected this guy to build a wall
we think a wall a stupid we don't think
it's gonna work we think it's kind of
embarrassing actually doesn't matter
we're gonna do it because you have
demanded it you have to kind of give
people a sense of the democracy is real
if they think it's fake they think it's
really an oligarchy posing as a
democracy what are they gonna do you
didn't want to think about that so just
practice democracy a little bit would
calm things down a lot is anyone doing
it better than us like for all the sort
of anger at each other right now and
it's funny cuz you know I spend time on
Twitter where it seems like the civil
war has begun already and then I get out
there in real life and I'm on this tour
and it's like I need thousands of peels
all across the middle of the country who
are wonderful and open and beasts and
things but I lost my question in that
what was the point of that show there
you see it I mean is it actually as bad
as it seems and as anyone any other
country more stable and happier than
ours oh that was it yes right is there
an example to look at because you I see
these people always complaining and as
you said it's easier to break things and
burn them down than it is to build so
all these people are always oh look at
these countries look at the you know
they always look at the Nordic countries
that seems to burn I think one look at
this Sweden and you know even though
Sweden's got all sorts of problems right
now you're one of the only people
covering it actually yeah I'm one of the
only suites on television maybe that's
why are you Swedish my name is Carlson
Oh
all right there you go I've got a lot of
Ikea no I'm not I'm not in any
meaningful sense we didn't I mean I
guess I am genetically so either stuff
like even care about that stuff
one 1020 exactly but I mean that those
are not models we can replicate for
obvious reasons it's a country of what
Sweden's got 8 million people yeah tell
me something that anyway
no who does it look nobody does it
better there's no greater country I
don't have a foreign passport I'm stuck
here I plan to do everything I can for
the country because I have a long term
interest in it and I don't want to move
anywhere else I can't think of any more
better how pynes what sounds pretty nice
but there's no humoral outside probably
that anyway the point is no you could
look at countries and see their ruling
classes doing things you wish ours did
there's no country I kind of despise
more than China but one thing I do
admire about China is that its ruling
clique thinks long Tong about stability
that's their overriding concern now of
course that's rooted in their desire to
hold on to power which is ignoble I get
it but they understand how important
continuity and stability are to the size
so they think deeply and they don't make
the right decisions all the time
obviously the one-child policy is a
disaster but they that's how they think
and I wish we thought that way I think
we've too internalized libertarian
economics as a model for everything that
like it's always virtuous to destroy
this thing and build something new and
what we don't understand is like that's
not people are not capable of that on
that scale like 325 million people can't
deal with tearing down and remaking the
society every generation they just can't
they'll go crazy and so we need to
identify the things that we want to
preserve and actively work to preserve
them and and I would start with the Bill
of Rights
so do you think any of the people right
here these beautiful character
caricatures of Maxine Waters and Mitch
McConnell and Nancy Pelosi who else do
we have on there I'm upside down Hillary
Clinton Bill Kristol mr. bird yeah
Bezos who's this I'm upside down here
that's Lindsey oh and Lindsey Graham oh
well okay so I actually wanted to sort
of get Lindsey into this somehow it's a
little pudgy er there than in real life
he's become sort of like like a star
subtly like what do you make up sort of
and rightly so these Republicans that
like even Mitch McConnell like they seem
like they've got a little juice at the
moment the Cavanaugh thing did something
well they did the right thing and
they're on the cover of my book not
because of that or any real political
reason particularly Lindsey Graham is
there and it's described inside he's the
embodiment and I like Lindsey Graham and
I think he's smart but he's the
embodiment of a phenomenon that I think
is really destructive which is the
refusal of people to learn from the
failures that that they created and so
like it's okay to have supported the
invasion of Iraq I did mm-hmm what's not
okay is 270 you know 15 years later look
at and be like no that wasn't a mistake
and no I refuse to learn from what
happened and yes I think we should do it
again like that that's something for
which she should be held responsible
that's my only point it's like I catch
my kids doing something wrong I'm not
surprised that they did something wrong
but I demand that they concede they did
something wrong and I make them try and
learn from it like that's just basic
yeah all right so let's do I know
there's nothing the people in television
like doing more than predictions we got
an election they don't like
accountability is the problem all right
so you seem pretty open to this so look
I had Glenn back on last week how is he
he was great he was look this is a guy
who if you haven't sat down with him and
how you oh okay good like this is a guy
who admits freely admits now that he was
part of the problem that he was one of
the people that led to the polarization
and he's trying to fix it yes I can't
you know people say well his motives he
just wants whatever money it it's like
people's moto or unknown yeah and I
don't want to attack people yes if you
repeatedly show me that your motives are
badly
but I see a guy who genuinely is trying
through to fix some things so when I
discussed this with him about the
midterms we sort of agreed basically
that the only option that I see that
it's remotely possible here for the
betterment of the country going forward
the Democrats kind of have to be
destroyed so that they can rebuild right
I don't otherwise if they do well in
these midterms we end up in two years of
impeachment and then it's like that that
revolution thing that you think we're on
the brink of I agree with that
and the reason is not because Trump is
inconvenienced or impeached or whatever
the reason is that the problems that led
to Trump's ascent are unaddressed I mean
that's that's the you know the the dying
of the middle classes is the core
problem and no one is talking about it
and Trump I have to say sometimes makes
it easier not to talk about it because
he seeks to be the person people talk
about anyway you know the problem yeah I
mean I think the ideas need to be
repudiated really clearly like you don't
win when you say that the guilty have an
obligation to prove their innocence I'm
sorry we're not rewarding that yeah what
was that the ultimate like sort of just
obvious way this all was gonna go like
everything with identity politics and
everything else and believe all women or
because when you group everybody you
can't have anybody that that wanders
like so the Cavanaugh thing really was
kind of the like it did it seemed
obvious to you it seemed obvious to me
that's what it felt like the way the
reactions were fully obvious and I mean
I got caught up I mean I say it's
obvious but I also got caught up as I
always do in my sort of literal like but
wait a second what about Ted Kennedy or
whatever when I should have been far
more sophisticated I said yet what you
just said which is of course they're
doing this because they have to do it
and this is kind of the logical apogee
of identity politics anyway that no one
is really human we're all just sort of
component parts of a larger whole of a
group and we have to act as a member of
a group we can never act alone
you know our unique humanity cannot be
acknowledged I mean you must think you
yeah you must deal with this all the
time yeah I mean I'm like a straight
or like you know whatever I guess I'm
acting according to type but if you're
not yeah you know you know so do you
know exactly talk about its yes and I
should have known that of course but the
point is I don't think that most people
buy that or want to buy they don't want
to live in that country where you're
required by your DNA to act a certain
way like what so what makes you
different from a robot at that point and
these are the exact same people who are
now defending Elizabeth Warren of course
could not be more fraudulent
have you had any have you had a Native
American tribes menorah Gore yes of
course I mean I have to say I think that
story for me has been a happy respite
from all this heavy stuff because it's
just so hilarious oh yeah how does it
reduce with this Loren is but I do think
there's a deep question at the bottom of
it not even at the bottom at the very
top of it which is like should your DNA
determine your life and maybe I'm just
too American or to California or
something but no I don't think it should
I don't think you're responsible for
what people you never met - I think
you're responsible for the decisions
that you make I don't think we should
hurt you because if your eye color or
your height or your race I mean like if
you start to accept that it's okay to
inflict group punishment on groups then
like I mean isn't that the whole lesson
of the 20th century that that's wrong
and that's a cul-de-sac that ends in
bloodshed yes so why are we accepting
this and every day on TV one of the main
products lycée don't say but one of the
main problems with our coverage is that
it's brought to us by dumb people and I
really think finance the whole finance
world is partly to blame forty years ago
like smart Evan Thomas from Newsweek
lives used to live on my street
many times a very smart guy went to
Harvard you know he's kind of liberal
whatever but he's in legitimately smart
smarter than I am he left Harvard and
went to work at Newsweek because that
was kind of an acceptable path now what
percentage of Harvard seniors are going
to Newsweek know they're going into
private equity so what you're left with
is almost it's almost like medieval
England where you know under
primogeniture that the first son gets
the estate and the second son has to
like figure it out or become an army
officer or a vicar or something it's
like we're getting the dung
people were getting the people who can't
think for themselves or all of a sudden
winding up his cable news anchors it's
like what do you know what I mean I do
know what you mean that's why I'm on
YouTube with all the smart people of
YouTube you know what I mean listen and
you know the first video that I did in
in 2018 was that I thought this was
going to be the year of unusual
alliances and I would say I would say
this is right up there because I
consider this a great alliance and I
think you're doing great work and all
that stuff not that you need me to look
anybody that it's really simple if you
if you feel a moral obligation to scream
at people in restaurants if you disagree
with their political views you're not on
my side and if you don't you are so it's
like I don't I mean this is such an
intense moment it's thrown everything in
the stark relief I just care about
aligning myself with people who believe
in the individual and freedom of
expression period I hear your brother
and for more on Tucker watch him on
Tucker Carlson tonight at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern on Fox News
[Music]